scoop internationale la semaine dernière
on découvrait pour la toute première
fois le visage d'alexander est elle là
vous savez qui c'est les jumeaux de
george clooney est absolument les ihm
jumeaux de george clooney et à mal la
même semaine
eva longoria a publié une nouvelle photo
de son bébé sur instagram
alors on s'est posé la question les
stars qui a exposé leurs bébés sur sur
les réseaux est ce que c'est bien est-ce
que c'est pas bien bien sûr vous a posé
la question sur les réseaux sociaux
en tout cas ce que c'est un passage
obligé pour les stars ont regardé puis à
prendre par le coup
un an et demi après leur naissance voilà
les bébés clooney roi des tapis rouge à
mal et georges les préserver
soigneusement des paparazzis mais là ça
ressemble bien à une présentation
officielle quand on est une star et
qu'on a un bébé
3 réactions possibles la première le
protéger en le cachant à tout prix des
regards indiscrets
marion cotillard et guillaume canet sont
des champions dans cette catégorie
personne n'a jamais vu le visage de
marcel photos prises de loin main dans
la main et dodo pour qu'on ne puisse pas
identifier le petit gars sont malins
dans la famille je protège mon enfant il
ya aussi jean dujardin pas une seule
photo de jeanne née il ya trois ans les
paparazzis n'essaye même pas mais pour
éviter la traque certaines stars
préfèrent contrôler la situation une
photo officielle
histoire d'avoir la paix on montre son
bébé une fois comme ça tout le monde le
voit et les paparazzis n'ont plus rien
de croustillant a dévoilé ce bon vieux
michael avait fait sa voix la blanquette
au balcon et puis après couverture enfin
il ya les stars qui sur exposé leurs
progénitures certains sont obligés
faire comme les princes d'angleterre
soumis aux protocoles des cas royalebaby
arrive il faut le montrer au monde
entier
georges charlotte et louis tous ont eu
droit à leur sortie de clinique
d'autres sont tout simplement gaga comme
kim kardashian qui fait de son fils un
acteur de télé réalité où caroline
receveur qui trimballe son fils partout
au point d'être accusé d'être une
mauvaise mère
ces stars qui exposent leurs bébés intel
raison ou pas alors raison pas d'exposer
leur bébé il ya beaucoup de wuala
j'avoue je suis surpris par vos réponses
mais c'est hallucinant alors moi par luc
forcément ça intéresse pour son magazine
mais les autres je suis vraiment très
très surpris à commencer par un nom
quand même guillaume la voix de la
raison
est-ce pourquoi c'est pas bien exposé
son bébé bah je sais pas mais quand on
voit caroline receveur ou les kardashian
besoin que ces races et ainsi un sac à
main quoi que c'est un outil qu'on
présentait comme monde c'est très
pratique ça leur fait de publicité
cet enfant n'a rien demandé je trouve ça
un peu indécent tout s'est très gadget
ouais et
ouais ça pour la montée c'est plein
c'est un clip promo il faut protéger les
petits qui n'ont peut-être pas qu'ils
n'ont pas demandé tout ça j'ai bien
compris ils ont rencontré le temple de
ta après mathieu parce que pour ça oui
c'est moi si complètement fou qu les
gens inconnus qui sont pas des stars
m'ont bien des photos de leur bébé de
leurs enfants oui pourquoi les stars
n'auraient pas les mêmes sentiments les
mêmes manières de fonctionner avec leur
jardin en plein qui montrent pas leurs
enfants et naviguant sur un stade à et
gérant qui cachent leur jeu et malgré
tout vous êtes intelligent je pense que
c'est la chose la moins 100 si tu as
entendu des bruits à ce que les gens qui
sont pas connus leurs enfants sont pas
connues c'était connu mon ton enfance de
nouvelles écoles partout où il va être
opéré mais attendez je parle du bébé
effectuons pour les enfants c'est
différent parce qu'ils ont grandi là
mais montrer un bébé comme ça on voit
que les enfants les finalement les bébés
de stars sont si mauvais pas la chose la
plus intime qu'on a un bébé mais
maintenant tout le monde mais combien
partage sa joie il n'ya pas d'aussi
actifs alors il ya votre copine à côté
par les stars font remarquer elles font
marcher leur business personnel
elles sont leurs propres marques et en
est le les longs moderate qu'on leur
fait d'ailleurs c'est leur audimat alors
à débattre personnel quand on met un
bébé que ce façon bébé même sur le banc
en danger ou un animal pardon à
comparaison on explose le nombre de
likes je vous invite à lever rien mais
vous pensez à vous là où vous pensez à
vous répondre et donc non mais je joue
bien je vous incite à le vérifier je
pense que les stars aussi valide leur
popularité sur les réseaux sociaux en
postant leurs bébés
il ya même le roux alors c'est pour
changer leur image le rappeur booba qui
n'est pas connu pour être le plus tendre
des mecs il pose très souvent avec celle
ci qu'il ya trois ans un peu plus grande
sur le botté à chaque fois qu'il la
poste il explose tous et l'ice à gré
donc je pense qu'ils aient un effet
d'image à la fois pour corriger son
image
et oui mais c'est quand je dis ça qu'on
vit dans le monde mais c'est bien quand
on est en train de me dire qu'un enfant
c'est un très bon outil pour gagner de
la popularité cieux quand on aura le
nombre des laïcs c'est terrible mais
c'est comme ça alors attends oui mais
c'est complètement un outil de promotion
d'ailleurs on a vu il ya pas longtemps
patrick bruel qui est alors lui au
niveau de la vie privée
au delà privé a toujours été très
agressif et là il a quand même explosé
ses enfants même si c'est un peu d'eau
il s'en sert pour quoi pour de la
promotion donc faire un album
oui mais ils sont grands les enfants on
a vu les efforts tisserand majeur johnny
a toujours protégé laura jusqu'à ses 18
ans donc voilà à partir du moment où on
met le pied là dedans et on se sert de
ses enfants pour la promotion après donc
c'est passé un week end un ami vous êtes
en train de lire à l'antenne regardez de
la démission que patrick pour la
première fois à parler et montrer son
enfant dans un corps d'homme et qui va
cartonner
ben je sais pas mais un changement il ya
un changement de tactique et d'attitude
dans tous les cas parce qu'on les a
jamais vus avant on les voit pas ok très
clairement c'est vastine et il ya quand
même une double page où ils sont dans
une réserve naturelle du pouvoir dire
aux d'accord papa on est d'accord pour
nous il est pas mal d'états majors bébé
serait le fait que c'est un outil de
promotion dont à bien sa large a gagné
avec n'a pas parlé non mais je me remets
la de ce que non mais est ce que patrick
bruel a besoin de ça je sais peur il le
fallait répondre moi j'étais un peu
comme comme mathieu je trouve que c'est
normal que les stars soient fiers de
leur bébé et démonte et et les bébés
quand vous dites les enfants n'ont rien
demandé moi je crois justement que quand
ils sont tout petits
ya pas trop de danger et c'est après
qu'il faut leur demander je suis sûr que
pas très blessures le bien qui fait dont
on se remet jamais vous ils disent tous
les pédopsychiatres vous diront qu
exposer son enfant sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est extrêmement extrêmement
risqué pour eux d'avoir du psychologique
bébé parce que du bain même bébé ou même
à 3-4 ans parce qu'ils sont exposés aux
et heure quand même qu'ils peuvent dire
ddd des saloperies sur eux qui peuvent
être hyper traumatisante et en plus de
ça enfin oui effectivement ils ont
raison si c'est dans tout retour de la
communication mais si on parle à
proprement parler n'est que pour
l'enfant c'est hyper chaud et là vous me
parlez tous deux comme on est d'accord
mais personne ne parle de l'enfant c'est
hallucinant c'est beau tout ça mais
c'est seulement ce que tu peut abîmer
ton enfant pour faire marcher sa
carrière il aimait ses parents exposé et
à l'enfant donc je gardais monique et
et deux choses de guérande entre montrer
son nourrisson pour le présenter comme
fait que les hôtels hilton et présente
son bébé au monde entier donc la
première photo qui est jolie elle est
belle comme la nature instagram ou que
je la mette sur la couverture de people
ou de lots comme c'est angelina jolie et
brad pitt pour 15 millions de dollars et
en présente les bébés après le bébé va
grandir on ne reconnaîtra plus et c'est
juste on présente son enfant le monde
c'est mignon tout le monde est content
c'est comme un faire part quelque part
déjà été maman je vous le montre et
après au après l'enfant met sa vie en
étant cachée et j'entends des magazines
et tout ça m'a glissé cours excusez moi
et que c'était un peu ringard j'adore
vingtaine de réseaux sociaux non mais
c'est vrai et les enfants c'est ce qu'on
a de plus beau je veux dire jean pas
pourquoi on va se priver de d'avoir une
photo avec nos enfants et violent qu'on
contrôle que c'est un trophée c'est un
être humain ce moment mon contrôle moi
je préfère contrôler ce que je montre
plutôt que ma fille et instagram par
exemple des enfants qui n'ont pas avoir
instagram par contre j'ai le droit de
mettre une photo avec ma fille je vois
pas où est le problème est un droit si
tu mets ta droits de tous on vit dans un
monde où heureusement ma droite je suis
je suis très curieux dans le sondage
parce que moi je suis atterrée par ce
que j'ai entendu crème sur le sur ce
sujet assure ça fascinant mais mais on
va regarder ce que pensent les gens
voilà les stars voilà voilà voilà non à
83% mais je suis d'accord que c'est
halal est ce que j'ai entendu c'est
hallucinant qui n'a pas un goût à partir
du touquet c'est près de 200 à l'enfant